LOUIS GRAY: Welcome to
Google Developers Weekly
for December 9, 2013.
I'm Louis Gray and this
is our highlight reel
of what's happening in the world
of Google Developers on the set
and off.
The big news from the
world of Google Developers
last week was the
general availability
of Google Compute Engine.
Our Cloud Compute
service offers 99.95%
monthly SLA, 24 by
7 service, support
for additional flavors of Linux,
reduced prices, and much more.
So you'll want to
check this out.
Alongside the launch of
Google Compute Engine,
Paul Rashidi debuted a
10-minute test drive here
on GDL-- walking us through the
process of creating a project,
setting up a cloud-based
virtual machine,
and installing a web
server-- very helpful.
And maybe even fun.
Our more grounded teammates
in Google Analytics,
Andrew Wales and
Nick Mihailovski,
told customers how to upgrade
to Universal Analytics
and answered some of the
many commonly asked questions
about the web's favorite
measurement tool.
Every click counts.
And don't we know it?
We were pleased to welcome back
Walleteers Peng Ying and Maru
Ahues Bouza.
The pair walked through the
Wallet Objects API Quickstart
sample, setting you up
to connect your business
to millions of Google users,
showcasing your loyalty
programs, offers, and more.
And Maps master Mano
Marks followed on
with his first event in his new
location, soon to be revealed.
This week's focus-- map padding
in the Google Maps SDK for iOS.
Map padding allows you to change
the visible region of your map
so that your controls,
logo, and copyright notices
are all aligned with your view.
From Milan, Sandro
Paganotti dives
into the promise of
HTML5 custom elements,
helping us create new
HTML code elements that
are reusable and readable.
Even more challenging, he
does the entire presentation
in Italian.
Incredible.
Wrapping up our studio
events for last week
is the first in a series from
our Google Developer Experts
team and the YouTube
developers squad.
Frequent GDL guest Jeremy Walker
talks with GDE Jarom McDonald
about the many contributions
that he and others
have made to the
YouTube API community.
Watch for more interviews
in coming weeks here
on the Weekly Wrap Up.
Around here, we think
fast is better than slow.
And we're always working
to make the web faster.
This week, web performance
guru, Ilya Grigorik,
wrote about HTTP 2.0--
a developing protocol
that makes applications faster,
simpler and more robust.
Read Ilya's article to
learn in great detail
how HTTP 2.0 will
speed up the web.
Just go to acm.org and search
for "making the web faster."
We also love making
it faster and easier
for you to develop
great mobile apps.
To help, Chrome
DevTools just got
a couple of wonderful
new features.
First, when you're
remote debugging,
Screencast lets you see
your mobile device screen
right along your tools.
And Mobile Emulation
lets you realistically
emulate many device
characteristics
on your desktop.
Read all about it
at html5rocks.com.
That's html5rocks.com.
And to make sure that you never
miss a thing from the world
of Google Developers, subscribe
to Google Developers on YouTube
and check out the GDL schedule
at developers.google.com/live.
I'm Louis Gray and I'll
see you in the studio.
[WHOOSHING]